[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what's up guys give it up for yourselves
for coming out tonight
[Music]
you please okay thanks
uh good to be here uh my name is hans
kim i will be uh the dating guru the
sherpa for your love life tonight
uh yesterday i actually talked to two
girls and uh
we talked about capitalism and
city
planning so you could say
it went well and i'm very well versed
uh tugging and women hey welcome youtube
do you guys want to sign up for the
whole show we got going on
yeah oh the buckets right here you can
slip your name in uh hello tonka good to
see you again
yoda for tonka
she's here again
are you also gonna sign up again
are you sure
we got too many dudes here as usual
we might have to make them date each
other
it's always my favorite thing to do
watching dudes try to [ __ ] each other
tonight we have a very funny guest and a
very funny comedian uh she is a winner
of a one-liner competition yet last
night give it up for the champion
heather keith
[Applause]
good to see you heather hello
how's your night been it's good
i don't know why you asked me on this
i'm terrified of
dating they're all the same they're all
the same they're gonna be five of them
up here tonight sick probably gonna be
the same people
uh so let's get started with a date and
uh let's see who's going to be the first
to come up here we got one gay person
here
i'll date them
is it a girl or a guy i think it's a guy
oh
so you can go on a date
i look enough
so the first person we have is uh derek
dimple
going on a date with holly johnson
wow give it up for this lovely couple
[Music]
did holly leave already
well she did she already left
she went to go sign up at a more
important thing i think that
it's not a referendum on you derek
she's just a hustler she loves comedy
rachel
you're right we'll be taking the place
of holly
there she is
rachel please make your way up to the
stage yeah
come have your first autistic date
you're welcome she lives in love
she lives
she lives in austin she's been on many
autistic dates oh wow oh already going
for the reach around holy [ __ ]
maybe stand directly behind her um
but uh this is derek and rachel and
they're just gonna go on a little date
give it up for them right now
hi rachel hi
nice to meet you nice to meet you yeah
how are things going oh things are
yeah i think you yeah you're welcome
yeah but if you're wondering if i do
anything to make it this way it's just
shampoo and conditioner it's just water
i'm so jealous i'm sorry
there was this super old lady at a
church that i went to like i was i think
i was like 24. i played in the band i
left religion at that point but but she
came up to me she's like in her 90s she
founded the church and she said young
man
i hope you know that you have the kind
of hair that women would kill for and
time
what a great story give it up for this
couple again
i somehow knew he would end on murder
god damn it
derek dimple
you are not a murderer he's not a school
shooter
have you uh ever picked up a school
shooter vibe on a date that you've been
on
rachel
you know
[Music]
if you date men i'm sure you have
we do most of the murdering
yeah we're pretty good at it yeah yeah
there's a scale and it's a spectrum it's
a spectrum it's a murder spectrum
yeah
so yes i have you've dealt with a lot of
spectrums especially right now
jesus christ
i'm just kidding you apologize it's fine
i'll let you guys in on that list
are you still doing the show on
wednesday oh okay all right
all right i'll put someone else on
two hour long show
he uh once booked a show with all black
people and they didn't find out it was a
black show until they showed up no no no
they knew like no
no no i told they knew much longer
beforehand i don't know why but black
people they hate surprises set up by
white neighbors didn't neither they
heard historically we're friends he's
name dropping what's happening
this is my only defense jamar neighbors
has really good hair too he is awesome
rachel i'm usually getting ignored on
this one
rachel i'm feeling a second day
love a man that plays hard to get
so rachel how long have you lived in
austin seven years wow so you're a
native lucky number pretty much
compared to us
where are you from
georgia oh okay
georgia georgia peach okay oh yeah
yeah
you're a southern dog quoting justin
bieber
you guys talked a lot about hair on your
date uh are you do you have any
experience in hair are you a hair
stylist
um
i like just no i don't yeah but
what do you do i feel very what do you
do for life yeah um for life for life
for work
i
like to paint wow
i know yeah do you do you like try to be
like pictorial like abstract what's i
i'm totally abstract oh just two
struggling artists up here you're an
artist
tell me i'm a comedian
see that's the funniest thing i said
doing great great date
uh so uh you know where would you go on
a second date with derrick
ooh
do you like bowling or putt-putt please
let her answer the question
okay you'd be fun at putt-putt yeah
yeah
he's excited
what kind of dude are you into usually
hmm sesame street
[Music]
[Laughter]
so derek what uh made you decide you to
grow your hair out oh i just uh just i
i've just neglect but they i kind of
conscientious neglect but yeah i wanted
to see i want to see if i could pull it
off and i think i did your hair grows
out in all directions at the same time
yeah
some people's hairs it goes straight
back but yours is more like a loofah no
i i have a picture of me in yosemite and
it's like kind of like this it's really
huge
yeah that's why uh you booked that all
black show because you have the same
type of hair as they do
uh but anyways uh so here's a great
first date question
who is the kindest person you know
rachel
is that really what you have here
these are the first date questions from
conversationstartersworld.com
[Music]
you want to go first
go first on this one if well i mean if
yeah
let's see
now there's some nice people in my life
for sure but you're stalling your
caretaker my grandma is your nurse she's
really nice
yeah and she you know yeah she she knows
how to like put her foot down when she
needs to but she's so but she's so good
to people that she generally doesn't
have to do that because people just
start acting the right way when they're
around her because she's so sweet and
conscientious oh that was such a genuine
answer
sign of a great date
[Laughter]
derek is your grandmother maybe a little
racist i i don't believe i would not why
would you she's a grandma
everybody has a racist grandmother no i
i i i wouldn't say so i think i mean why
i mean i think i think i think everyone
has ever heard
their thoughts in their brains but you
know i i don't want to say anything bad
about my grandmother i love her very
much my grandma's super racist nicest
woman in the world
[ __ ] yeah well you've achieved a new
level of honesty that i'm
only aspiring too
a nice grandma
and a nice mom
uh you're a painter
uh
you ever paint your
not racist mother
how not racist she can be
i'm not really into painting people
you said abstract stuff yeah i don't
want to offend it oh he was listening
good listeners
wow
derek meeting the basic requirements of
being a human being
aka superman
it's a very low bar for us men as a
woman you have to take mediocrity into
account
congratulations derek you're the most
eligible bachelor thank you so far
because you remembered something said
five minutes ago oh yeah uh derek what
kind of art do you do you uh you do
comedy but besides that do you do any
other artistic endeavors yeah i just
came from a music open mic i played some
songs for them i've been trying to
refine that a bit i've been doing music
along you sing i do sing yeah i would
love to hear it
no i like a whole new world because it's
too white people doing a middle eastern
thing
i'm just on a race kick tonight please
keep going that's what the show is based
on i think walt disney was racist
or he was dead probably
okay just whenever you feel like it
start singing oh but this is i think
this is beauty and the beast
oh no it's not
but are the words going to come or no
it's just up to you just make it up i
can show you the world
shining shimmering splendid
now the words have changed and my
brain's not keeping up with this i think
i'm gonna
he's serenading the whole audience
rachel
that was your turn
i don't know the words either
and i'm coming in the middle of the
verse
they're gonna [ __ ]
keep singing
this is the chorus
[Music]
point of view
tell me
please don't talk about other songs give
it up for them they just did it
hodgepodge
of a song
got your true personality so uh let's
just do an improv exercise let's pretend
that you're a princess jasmine and
you're
you're uh you have to marry this uh
this mage who has like a parrot
and uh derek comes in to town with an
elephant
and uh he's putting on a big show but
you don't know if you yeah i [ __ ]
love aladdin
yes and that's the scene and uh go
oh raj i'm just not into this king i
wish a
wonderful strapping man with the fro
would come in on a elephant
what do you think raj
raj
did i hear wonderful strapping man with
a fl fro coming in on an elephant
who are you psy i am
alia babwa
ding
i have heart eyes
hard eyes i
have
don't say it
gonna get canceled
hard thoughts for this mage who's trying
to take you away
nice save please kill him
yes let me rub on my lamp really quick
but i have to turn my back while i'm
doing it
take the lamp out of your pants
i took it out of my pants here it is
and seen
wow give it up for these improv actually
that was wonderful
you guys crashed that i thought derek
would be the murderer but turns out it's
rachel yeah
we've come full circle
okay can i confess something yes oh my
god a murderer what
so i was supposed to go on a date today
oh
and
he totally like flakes what a loser
but this is way better where did you
meet him um through a friend
really do you know what he looks like
yeah
does he have a throw i was gonna say
does he have a nose piercing because
those guys do that [ __ ]
they have a very nice nose piercing
heather keith using personal experience
sorry guys i i have trauma you're going
to hear rachel would you
can't read social cues
so what's the fastest that a guy's moved
on a date before
have you do you have any crazy stories
about
like guys that are just boundary-less
she's going back in her vault
he's like which story
oh my gosh
is this live anywhere this is on the
internet
right now um
use pseudonyms change the location
no i can't show it because it's the
person i was supposed to see today
oh
[ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that
guy [ __ ] that guy
um what can you reveal about this yeah
like we're supposed to go out today
who's his name give us just a first name
frank yeah oh
what is he 70 years old
yeah
i've never heard that name before that
sounds so fake
does he own a car mechanics shop no
that is a frank thing to do i just see
it on a name tag what does he work at a
hot dog stand
am i right
[Laughter]
um
yeah well this was our second date today
we were supposed to that's funny he was
already planning the third date via text
and we were wait what was the excuse for
the flake
no response whoa
ghosted
seriously that's [ __ ] well i'm a man
of my word i won't flake on you if i say
i'll be somewhere i that is
derek
saying all the right things [ __ ]
if only we could all be like derek
oh man this feels great
it started out with us making fun of you
for being autistic and now we're
complimenting a chivalry so
that put everything on my hair early on
i wow
just wow can i say
it's uh been a great date i hope that uh
you can do an abstract painting of the
guy that didn't show up
because he's just uh he's just an idea
he's just a rage painting darkness
red and black but thank you guys so much
for kicking off the show and i hope you
guys have a great second day have a
great day
great date great day
great night
they're still
talking send in the link
for this youtube send frank this link
i was gonna say we're making
relationships but if anything we're
making babies me and you
not directly we're making babies other
people are making babies for us
all right uh
is anastasia here
anastasia in the front row
get up here baby going on a date with
sam kuiper
where's sam where's timothy
what sam's right there oh sam
anastasia please come on up to the stage
you're going on a date looks not bad
baby
sam is a gentleman yeah what a gent
loves the ladies
and sam
russia
from russia with love yes from russia
yes but i've been living here for a long
time so how long is a long time um what
do you consider to be a long time
over 10 years oh yeah that's a long time
for sure i was going to say less
uh
all in austin you moved to austin or
where you were no i'm actually from
florida oh god um
i would are you from california or
something no no i'm from alabama
not too far too much
what part of florida um
daytona
port orange but it's right next to it
it's like spring break city over there
right you like to party
um not into parties that much anymore no
just vodka by yourself not with friends
lonely evenings yes one of those
what brought you to austin
uh work okay what do you do uh i'm in
yours oh sweet are you like a travel
nurse i am actually yes awesome that's
like uh
you just go on like little contracts and
like
stay work
they can be alone why do you know
anything about are you a nurse no no i'm
not a nurse and time he's not a nurse
he's nursing this conversation
so
sorry
i was going to say i like how you kind
of like
ugged at the fact that she lived in
florida like she's supposed to know
she's gotta know
yeah
i don't think we like divided people
like what's a place where if someone
said they were from there in russia
you'd be like ugh you caught people from
alabama do you know where ala yeah never
mind dumb question yeah no well that
wasn't a stupid question but since
she goes by florida of course she does
i'm sure is it sweet home alabama oh
yeah
she's an american you guys
certified how long have you been in
austin uh about eight months not that oh
eight months that's cool yeah i i like
it what was your first impression
um it was hot and rainy thank you yeah
what month did you come uh april i came
in june yes super hot and the roads do
you like the roads what about them
they were horrible
in what way a russian telling us our
infrastructure sucks yeah
we have nothing like the kremlin
what are the roads like in russia
i've been living in u.s since i'm like
21. you just forgot about it i mean yeah
you haven't driven it yeah but um
they're interesting and russia they're
very interesting and it's like um
it's not a good word to describe roads
i don't want to drive on an interesting
road
trails there
have you only lived in florida and texas
in america uh i've traveled around okay
like i've been i was gonna save you that
means you're not american
what did you guys say no i was just
talking about the weather is dumb as
[ __ ] the weather
like you missed the [ __ ] snow am i
right
i do i miss it
when's the last time you went back to
russia this year in may or april was
your fam all your family there yes you
the only one that moved here
yes yes
i know just
how cute a russian named anastasia adore
she's getting overwhelmed
away from that communist
you guys made fun of my roads i'm out of
this conversation the people right
people in america are not like anywhere
else
that's what the first thing that came to
my mind is people right and christmas
christmas christmas
wait what you guys just go from december
24th to december 26th in russia
skip right over you guys don't have
christmas in russia but you have bears
do you have bears why do you guys have a
bear here well for you
baby so comfortable it's creek in the
cave and we're in the cave [ __ ]
welcome to the [ __ ] day cave
the day goes wrong you're gonna get
eaten yeah
or if it goes right you can get eaten
too you don't know that no matter what
no matter what it's gonna be dark
yeah yeah
um
what was the question was russia
wait let's go back to the date questions
i want to read one of them
you're a nurse wait can i read your
notes right now
please don't
i do want to that'd be funny okay russia
florida alabama vodka nurse
those are key words people
he's skewing up his rifts i love it
if i go to a hospital i'd want the
non-vodka nurse you had to work an
android you broke [ __ ]
yeah i live in a van
he does
um so you are a traveling nurse and uh
we are living during a pandemic what was
life like for you in april
21. very nostalgic wow yeah it's
horrible um
yeah shut up
so you're not up here right now
can i ask you okay no yeah go ahead okay
i was gonna ask one of these date
questions fun among your friends what
are you the best known for
what what are you best known for
uh i'll start
uh i guess uh just
smiling and always being happy that's
what everyone's oh shut up tell us for
real
i did tell you for real he's like
getting drunk and hiring a hooker at the
end of the night no really
uh i don't know man i do so like i don't
know i'm a
like artistic kind of guy i do like
music and like uh i recently have gotten
into stand-up but i started like acting
in theater so i don't know i mean i'm
just like a very personable person in
alabama you are known as a [ __ ] yeah
that is what they say
that's why
and here too
[Laughter]
the gayest alabaman
that
they have in alabama sam kuiper
anastasia what are your friends what
does tonka know you for
just
that i like her a lot and that i'm
russian i don't know
russia
any hobbies any like
anything like that i've been horse
riding today oh that's so russian in the
rain oh god damn russian i love this did
you have your shirt off like vladimir
putin
on the horse
oh we offended her no she's about to go
into another documentary speech
the year was
my pony
she broke her eyes
wait you owned a horse
no it was not mine oh did you steal a
horse
where would i keep it if i would steal
it
thinking ahead
an animal advocate uh so you you rode a
horse today it was raining today not not
where i was driving riding it
nice
yes
you ride a horse in flugerville that
sounds like a country song
uh why do they have horses in
flugerville
they bring them from rockdale
if somebody basically
books
a ride
where did you like is there trails in
flugerville i don't know there was some
kind of field and we just like just an
open field yeah just an open that's cool
just you and your did tonka go with you
or uh no it was a friend of mine
a date a guy friend
very nice guy i wanted to i didn't want
to i didn't i came here how dare you
like double stuff he's not supposed to
take to to write my name so he's
watching that like
oh is
it was weird oh my god it was weird
weird nowadays oh your whole dating life
like have you been uh going on a lot of
first dates when i came here yeah hinge
bumble and then i just i was just like
i'm not doing it yeah
welcome to america what about what about
uh what about you big boy
what's your dating life like
uh
i just got out of a relationship
recently i was dating this girl for like
a month and a half and she
broke up with me because she said i knew
what i wanted which was confusing
that's not how that's supposed to be
i want a guy
[Music]
she's right there thank god
he's like i will show you the world
he's funny are you gonna [ __ ] him
that didn't get a laugh and that felt
weird
i didn't like that
she's really contemplating over there
what's going on
anastasia what are you thinking about
never ask about russia what they're
thinking about potato vodka that's what
she was thinking about
what uh
what what kind of guy was this that you
went horseback riding with
good looking
a strapping stallion of a man yeah
yeah there you go that's good so nothing
like sam keiper
i'm just kidding sounds very
good-looking but you know what's awesome
that that girl told you about a dead
girl what did you say
you know what's awesome that that girl
told you about it one month and a half
instead of waiting for it for a year or
something she still said deadpool yeah
that's true
yeah thank you it's just [ __ ] be
doing that
[ __ ] be wasting your time i know
because i'm [ __ ]
give it up for sam kuiper and anastasia
they just went on a date together
[Applause]
can i go grab another beer yes uh can we
get some table service i think we can
get this oh i was just gonna run to the
green room okay that's fine
ray chenevy in the house
recently on the secret show
uh let's get another date up here let's
get cody stillman to be the man
here he comes
and there's only one girl left
holly holly are you here
still
jubilee
in the front row going on a date with
cody stillman yeah yeah yeah beauty and
the beast wow i love it already
let's see what happens a burnett and a
blonde let's go to a bar ugly
i called you a beast like beast mode
like okay
okay
cuddy's not gonna kill me uh let's go on
a date with jubilee and cody give it up
for them one more time
what's up
not much how's it going
uh it's going good i came out to this
because hans invited me so i'm here i
don't know i guess we're going on a date
uh i've been on a lot of dates i should
be good at this but welcome i haven't
been on a lot of dates really no with in
the age of tinder like you're not oh i
tried but it's people will probably tell
me my profile sucks i get no responses
you get no likes on tinder
so instead of living with that constant
like
drag on my emotions i just deleted it
okay now i come to weird dating shows
yeah i mean you know and see how that
plays out for me yeah it could work out
you never know uh
i gotta give them here
i mean i came here for true love
personally yes same i i'm really looking
for my soul mate here yeah i was like
i'm expecting it kind of because like
hans told me that i would find my soul
mate so
for for me it's really just that if
you're not out looking for it you're
never gonna find it exactly you gotta do
encounters spent far too many especially
since coven days at home just talking to
my cats about why am i alone
end time
not the image that i would want to
portray on a date too that actually
works
oh yeah you guys both have cats i talk
to them too i can't find anyone either
so what can i say
you guys are both talking to cats what
do you say to your cat cody to your
[ __ ] talk to the boy cat because he's
the most talkative back the girl cat
just looks at me and then curls up in my
lap typical
but the boycott always wants to be
outside so i'm usually telling him that
it's cold outside and i don't want to
open up the door baby
you're sexually assaulting your male
cats what about your cats do you talk to
your cats yeah absolutely yeah they uh
they cuddle with me i have one cat she's
a girl hey guys i have cats too i'm also
here yeah
let's not forget heather
shut up i really just talked to her like
in a baby voice like she's my child of
course
that's a red flag
can you pretend cody is a beautiful
he pretend cody is a beautiful female
cat and uh
let's let's see a little example of how
you talk to your cats jubilee
she can't do it
it's so embarrassing like it's like it's
so extra it's like as embarrassing as
possible let's see it
oh god
hans please ask anything else i'll do it
he wanted it i'll talk to cody like
you're you're a cat like how i talk
hey
look at your nice little
wait i looked up i looked up questions
that are better than your questions
she found a better website yeah there's
it's called team building
this is the corporate
icebreakers who was a who was your
childhood famous
crush ooh that is a good question i
really liked arwen from lord of the
rings uh wow
a lesbian you look i die as [ __ ]
that was my bisexual awakening was okay
wow
how old are you i'm 27. so who uh did
you have a crush on maybe like a
magazine i'm trying to think as i know
i'm sure i had one or two
in there god i can list so you know what
my sexual awakening is so many my sexual
awakening was a beast boy from teen
titans
yeah okay
titans puts
[Music]
yeah but she goes the baddest [ __ ] of
them all just because she was evil
doesn't mean she wasn't like that's true
what about arwen
she was pretty badass definitely that
the there's something about a woman with
a sword that is incredibly attractive
yeah she can kill you and she's like an
elf so she's like arya's star
all right with their little needle
she's like just being a nerd i mean such
a [ __ ] narrative
um
what about natalie portman
she's hot yes that's my crush yeah so
you have to think about that that's
that's
right yes yeah [ __ ] yeah honestly you're
saying natalie portman was pretty hot
yeah now she's like
this not doing acting or anything
she's just hot now um
anyways let's go back to my list of uh
more [ __ ] you know multiple drugs
yeah you guys look like you're about to
go
in the woods you found the right guy
like you had like a shroom trip and
discovered empathy
someone sell me shrooms in a very long
time if you know someone let me know
i don't know
on sixth street and start shouting it's
pretty easy to find you just have to be
brave what's the last drug you've done
oh weed does that really count anymore
no it doesn't okay i'm talking about a
real drug weed doesn't count definitely
molly i did mushrooms i met some guy who
was like i'm a photographer i'll take
pictures
so we did some mushrooms he was chill
okay he was all right
that's a good uh
update after that was that a date
i guess i mean you know it's one of
those things where like heath definitely
thought it was a date
hmm
yikes
i've never been invested today
i've been on a few of those we realized
about halfway through like
i need to make this less i'm the worst
like no one should go on a date with me
i'm so sorry but both of you what what
are your dating lives like
um this i go on like a lot of dates uh
because i i really like talking to
people and meeting them but i've noticed
that like the dating culture is like you
gotta bang right away like there's
pressure the pressure is on and if you
don't bang immediately
you are a piece of [ __ ] you
so i hate that and i'm really bad at
that so like i've just been like well i
guess i'll just tell everyone i'm not
interested and just make them force them
to hang out with me
cool
if you don't have sex on the first date
it's like the filter we're like they're
scary as [ __ ]
get away from me i mean we met on tinder
but i'm sure you're talking about other
guys i was gonna say
i've seen her around
yeah
we were we went out to a lot of michaels
you guys [ __ ] on the first date
we did
do you want to tell them about her first
date we oh my god can i yeah i tell
everyone
she's telling a story
um so i matched with hans and his like
profile said joe rogan's opener and i
think you flies
i thought it was a joke that's a name
i did not put that there i didn't think
it was real
my friend brittany ledesma hijacked my
tinder profile oh sure
to be fair
that would be on my tender profile all
right what else am i going to use
he's like come out to my comedy show
it's gonna be a really good one and i
was like huh okay
i guess so we'll see what's what this is
and then i go out and like i have no
idea like i didn't even i don't know
i was waiting outside they were like i'm
waiting for hans and everyone's like
yeah we know hans and i was like okay
and then he came out he took me in
and then uh yeah he took me into the
back room and i met joe rogan
uh and tony hinchcliffe and ron white
[Music]
talked to all of them ron white shook my
hand he liked me and then you said oh i
guess i'll [ __ ] him i guess i'll [ __ ]
hans yeah we could actually
we didn't [ __ ] him in his van in his
family
you don't have to tell her that part
no i'm telling her that part because you
didn't tell anyone about that you just
did mouth stuff what happened
i don't even remember exactly i remember
the guy gave him my hand and yes
but uh what does his dick look like
what is hanza's dick like i kind of want
to no stop shut up we're talking about
him
i'm sorry it's okay if you ask this this
what's your name
jubilee yeah cody
calm down
cody you were saying you were going to
talk about your last dating experience
oh yes so my last date uh equally
humorous but for a completely different
reason i ended up vomiting mid sex with
my date that's why oh you've been on the
show before i have yes yeah you told us
about this i did but there's a new
audience i'm sure yeah it was uh so you
haven't dated in a while
it's first date in a while and this is
why i think that sex on the first date
absolutely sucks because you vomit yeah
apparently i have a panic attack halfway
through it was someone had the lovely
excuse of oh it's my my antidepressants
are just not making me
happy and able to do this and i should
have remembered that that would have
been a much better thing to say than try
to have sex the girl and then have a
panic attack halfway through and then go
oh god excuse me i need to go vomit
at least you said excuse me
yeah a gentleman it was a very polite
interaction a bulimic gentleman
then she got to uh spend an hour like
me which was super weird
oh yeah weird oh yes uh i gotta be into
that whole time oh my gosh who wants to
be naked that's just great just imagine
it you know completely naked she's
wandering through my kitchen looking for
my cups
naked woman in your apartment what are
you going to do
well
did she hold your hair back as you
vomited
no
apparently she was drunk the whole time
because this is why there was no second
date she told me she didn't remember any
of this
she was like blackout drunk for the
entire interaction okay cody don't want
to say that online
i'm not how do you not have confidence
you're [ __ ] someone you already did
this is what i'm here to gain his
confidence come up on stage and talk to
people i'm panicking right now leaning
back you look confident you were talking
on the in the audience the whole time
you have the confidence enough to uh
interject i might throw
the gay bucket is probably the best this
is so bad for the gay person not being
homophobic bisexual i'll date the gay
person are you bi i could be yes okay
there's a sliding scale there's so many
buys on this section
yes i'd be a bottom you're a bottom what
are you what are you a bottom two so
i could be a top no
but that's just so much extra work
i tried
it's just awkward you know like we're
both trying to be like
i just want to sit here i want you to do
all the work we're trying to make it
work and it's not working on this list
that i brought up one of the questions
is just is hugh grant funny
and i love that when was this written in
the 90s
who the [ __ ] cares about hugh grant
anymore um let me let me find a good
question chris pratt for the 2000s
um
what is an easy item on your bucket list
that you haven't done yet you do like
hash browns like extra crispy
okay but i'm cursed by my father who was
a short order cook and he said hash
browns are yesterday's fries they
couldn't sell that's i'm fine with this
[Music]
mine's biscuits and gravy
and gravy are good as [ __ ]
she's just she's just asking questions
she wants to say yeah i really am
eggs benedict i like that oh that oh
[ __ ] me up i'm about to go to a diner
after this yeah i'm going to gym
sponsored by ihop
i'm super late i'm going to go to the
gym
i eat it with a bunch of i think it's
butter and jam and i put a lot of stuff
on my oatmeal it's basically dessert for
breakfast it's just has that consistency
yogurt it's mostly sweet not quite
yogurt no it's not okay
that makes sense you're wearing a
bandana oh yeah
is that just your vomit from the day
before yeah he did it okay okay no one
like that um
so you guys went on a date i thought it
was very beautiful i thought yeah you
guys are both yeah
did holly we can always convince a girl
oh you're here oh hollywood
you
i love you holly we're going to get you
up here in two seconds you're the only
other girl give it up for jubilee and
cody the drug addicts
in a good way
[Applause]
come on up here and be weird okay
we're just gonna have holly date the
rest of the men
give it up for holly and errol and if
there's any women that want to sign up
please go ahead and sign up if i date
all the men i'm not going to post
pictures of every single one of them i
make out with like hans on facebook
[Laughter]
you post pictures of who you make out
with
me is that what you said no hans does
you do that huh i'm not here you guys
are dealing with each other oh yeah
all right starts now
and you're at a macaroni grill
how do you like the macaroni grill
wasn't my first choice but you know i
can't win them all no you just kind of
gotta take and get so i'm i'm with you
there macaroni grill is fine i mean i'll
find something i'm not a picky [ __ ] you
know a waitress is a [ __ ] though let me
tell you about it
[ __ ] her i'll trip her no i won't i
would never do that she's been arguing
on the phone with her stepson in the
back closet the whole time oh wow they
weren't kidding about you
[Laughter]
me too we'll go all right so she's in
the back closet what the [ __ ] happened i
forgot i can't do improv
you dragging me in [ __ ] i was ready to
just hang out and you're like
let's build it let's try something new
today
i'm sorry we're still in it yes okay
this is great it's so nice it's nice
thanks how old are you i feel like
you're a lot older than me
[Laughter]
um yeah when i asked you to just get you
know if you wanted to get in my van and
go on this date you know i mean you know
you were here i mean no i'm 36. your 30s
call how do you know i haven't been no
here's it it's called stand-up comedy
as a cult leader i for sure know holly
would not
she would he would figure too much [ __ ]
out should use her right in a sorority
that's basically yeah
that call you pay for but you were
that's all cults yeah
is it
scientology mormonism already [ __ ] got
them out of it yeah yeah you pay it like
rent
like every month so is it just rent and
then you call it sorority or is it
different i mean i know you live
together but rent a friend
that sounds actually pretty nice how do
i sign up for running terrible bits up
here what how do you sign up for it yeah
i'd love to you have to do there's a
thing called rushing where basically you
have to meet every sorority you have to
introduce yourself you have to you have
to talk to like several members of each
one and at the end they rank you
so they rank how much they want you
on a scale that's literally online
dating with no sex
how do you know there's no sex
lesbianism
happening
so uh you guys are uh age difference uh
you're very old for the record i would
[ __ ] 24 year old no problem okay we are
sure that you have but we didn't want to
talk about that yeah errol dear don't
count
what to hear
you're saying he [ __ ] deer yeah do you
know how hard i'm off my game today
i knew one guy turned into an army
ranger but he was able to jump out of a
pickup truck and tackle a deer
[ __ ] it you know i mean how hard that
would be
just give it up yeah i love all women i
like that you think women are just like
what do you think though
we i know i'm an idiot
you're an improv master you're a
connoisseur of comedy what uh what kind
of scenario do you think would be a
hilarious situation to be in with uh
autistic holly johnson why am i this one
i mean this is you just
told us like in great detail what it's
like to be in a sorority with numbers
and all that that makes me you have a
spreadsheet at home i'm sure
it's kind of kind of autistic
um
i love you that's so funny
yeah
all right
doesn't mean you're in a culture yes
because literally can we break this up
which yeah this is too cold [ __ ]
rigid we need to get more love if i fell
through some ice cream
are you polar bear you're dressed for us
which beverage goes best with pizza oh
my god
that's a good one there's no options i
just have to come out yeah
what do you what do you drink with pizza
i would say a nice craft beer whoa
[Music]
like a rose i like the rose nice subtle
flavor did you know it's the highest
energy uh organism on the earth and i'm
autistic i have no idea what you're
talking about are you talking about over
this i came up with the question myself
are you guys thank you i'm ready for it
original if you were a spice girl which
spice girl would you be
[Music]
everybody hates this [ __ ]
an autistic spice
i have a confession i don't know any of
this [ __ ] all right next question
guys i thought it was a spike what about
what jonas brother would you be holly
what jonah's married
who's the one that like abandoned
everybody
the bonus jonas
just i mean since you don't know it'd be
pretty interesting holly gary jonas
sporty jones oh for the for the spider
baby
no i already said to kevin i'd be the
kevin yeah you're right kevin
kevin 11. you for sure know the spice
girls though right for sure i know all
right which one would you be sporty
okay all right it's fine what is what
does that mean does that mean he's like
in uh look into it
i don't know not like moving around and
she seemed to have a good time
you seem like babies
[Music]
you read me so well so uh you guys what
are your dating lives like errol are you
uh currently in a relationship are you
single are you uh you know in an open
relationship
yeah are the other ones you want to go
through are you celibate or you
involuntarily or voluntarily celibate
i have been into edging lately but it's
not quite the same thing
um i uh this is when he parks the van
too close
it is
it's edges life i mean everything
everything's edging um
but uh you know i'm on i've been on
tinder for a fair amount of time i
caught out of a you know i've had
probably five or six two-year
relationships
in my life date a lot of white women for
about two years wow have you ever
only white women yeah i'm from the i'm
from the the i'm from i'm racist
by default i mean yeah kinda but i mean
yeah i'm from the pacific northwest
where there's not a whole lot of other
things besides white people and so um
you know you just kind of you are where
you are and now you move to austin brown
people everywhere shut up that's not
come hang out
but heather is like not brown you're
pretty they were they were in my high
school there was a hundred dollars
yeah i'm white past 100 in the
graduating class and in that of that of
the four
grades in the high school there were
three folks of color
have you only [ __ ] white
what the [ __ ] people of question is that
it's a valid question he doesn't like no
i have not always doesn't like hard
answers questions
yeah cause you were talking about or
have you only made love together yeah no
i've
i make love to a lot of people uh what
about you guys
you're under arrest chris hansen
i feel like i feel like you've never
been [ __ ] by a black guy i feel like
you're right
i feel like i've never had feelings down
there because i'm not about it
that's because they have large [ __ ]
yeah because because big weenies um i
mean uh asian people are small
butweenies so how do you know that uh
just like
surveys
demographic data
um the [ __ ] are you
that's you i got it years ago man i
followed it thank you don't need the
recap
very self-conscious
lashing out
what is your kiss this time everyone's
well i don't know um
i would say
i don't have a very racist family we
just have a very wife and my dad's
mormon which is kind of a weird race are
they like passive-aggressive racists or
i'm not talking full-on i'm talking
about for the record i've never admitted
my family is racist you've just assumed
so and then started you're white
yesterday
i don't think my family i mean my family
doesn't know that they say things that
they can't say anymore but they don't
say it that's what i mean they don't say
it because they're they're racist they
think they're be they think they're
doing the right thing they're just not
yeah
ain't that the truth kind of loud in
this movie theater
maybe they're just like uh you know like
they're they're not aware they're like
uh they don't know that it might be
racist well i feel like now like if you
like someone sneezes and you don't say
bless you that's racist like
everything's racist now okay racist
you got her
nice i just feel like i can't say
anything now i'm so glad i came back to
this walk two blocks to be called racist
and autistic
right off the bat they didn't even
actually working
at the open mic with another racist
artist he calls it derek or an autistic
racist now he's on a second date
you're doing great
devastating
that date there would have been some
reason
i have a real question can i ask a
question hans please ask a real question
it's going to be a real one and now i'm
on my second beer so yeah that's a
casual sunday night it's casual i have
work at 7 00 am i'm fine
she's fine leave her alone
she doesn't need an intervention going
to a diner what caused you two months
ago to stop drinking i kept sending boys
i liked like very emotional texts and i
was like okay i need to
i need to cut this out this feels bad
yeah that's not autistic it feels bad
yeah
yeah see hans emotions let me explain to
you what emotions are oh yes holly
please explain to me what an emotion is
break it down holly johnston this is
perfect i would watch that podcast right
there just you two sitting and just
talking emotions with each other i felt
anger yesterday oh tell me what that's
like it felt like a red blanket
i feel very emotional
are we gonna make holly date someone
else holly do you want to go on a date
with someone else sure all right aaron
hey well
has something to say i got one more okay
if i can just because we're all doing
that we're all autistic thing i got my
favorite me being called out for being
autistic and they're right uh story real
quick i'll make it fast hans hang on can
i are you gonna act out no i'm not gonna
act out bro i'm just having a
conversation
okay so i was working at university of
oregon and so i got myself a place
and so i had some roommates to make it
easier and so i found this guy on
craigslist whose name was cyril
and he was like 60 and he was a chef and
i trust chefs yeah so
i'm like all right and we just said cool
cool and so he's going to move in now
he's like a little zen master he's just
like grows weed in the backyard chills
out after work does cheffery stuff it's
cool we're all good you know if you want
some chicken i made some chicken and uh
you know if you want to not be out here
at 11 o'clock at night when it's raining
working on the thing or whatever and i'm
like oh cool thanks man and he comes
over
and he goes hey can i just ask you
something and i go what he's like
you like autistic or something
i was like
oh yeah for sure thanks for asking that
was a super autistic story yeah yeah
just the way that you told it um i don't
think that uh the payoff was worth it
was there a punchline is there like a
second part to it or
the punchline was the thing where
there's some patience involved with this
game my man but no no there's probably
[ __ ] i know that's what you rely on
it's a [ __ ] story i'll get out sorry
i'm 24. i'm on tick-tock all day i don't
have an attention span please put it in
and i don't want to waste your time
oh here we go i'm getting out hey give
it up for arrows
you're gonna go on a date with a guy
that can actually tell a story give it
up for saul lozano
harry cubs uh-oh
uh drove in from colorado
um i've had like six beers tonight
okay
feeling good i like austin austin is
cool dawson is cool
um
uh what are you what do you do in
colorado
i i i'm a chef surprisingly is that are
you really uh
yeah
yeah no i uh
jack's fish house and oyster bark are
you sure that's not like a brothel no no
it's not people and time
sorry you did great saul
oysters
state i love that
oh absolutely wait where are you from in
colorado fort collins colorado okay
i
yeah i got i got a little drunk tonight
uh we thought there would be less
autistic people on stage a week last
year but we got more and we were hoping
for a non-autistic school
mary's mountain cookies
that's literally mary's mountain cookies
is literally next they're really hitting
it off
it's really inspiring to see you guys
just hitting it off you guys both have
the similar uh skin
similar autism
wait are you white no you're calling me
out you don't even know me
i just saw you like stare at a woman's
feet jewish
what are you white that's awkward that
that didn't land no i knew that i knew
it
mexicans gave me away
have you ever dated a white woman
and the fact that he works in a kitchen
so you're a full mexican yeah
what gave you away
my whole life and what did you uh who
did you hang out with in high school
stoners
were you like the type of stoner that
like
gave up on life or the stoner who just
did it casually you know for a little
while yeah i was the starter that gave
up that was me
it took me five years to graduate high
school because of it
thanks donors thank you
they were all hanging out under the
bleachers together yeah um so what did
you uh what did you do in high school in
terms of dating did you date like
a fellow stoner did you guys smoke a
joint yeah what's your dating life like
i want to know this song how old are you
by the way you just turned 24 22
i'm actually 26 this year really
wow yeah thank you wow
you're welcome
what's your nerdy thing i uh i play a
lot of magic the gathering you play
guitar
she wants to date a white guy that's why
she
go with what you know am i right
no i like uh i like miniature board
games i like miniature board games sure
the big ones are too big
they are too big i don't like gi joes
they're too expensive
oh a purist
this guy's got standard dessert island
yeah it doesn't yeah okay wait give me
i'm drunk
you are stranded on a remote desert
island are you alone
or are you you your worst enemy
what what are you what the [ __ ] are you
alone are you sure you read that right
or with your worst enemy because you're
alone you get that off a bad
[Applause]
wait there was one on here that i
thought would be good do you want to
answer that what movie do you wish you
could watch for the first time again do
you want me to answer the first one or
the second no the second one [ __ ] the
first one i thought it would be funny no
one liked it
um for me i gotta think of her for a
second
50 first
date she watches that over and over
again
i would say something
wholesome like toy story
just like get get that okay get that old
nostalgia back yeah that's so creepy
wait how do you say it say it one more
time nostalgia
i heard the way he says colorado so
where are you how do you say colorado
colorado
colorado
[ __ ] hated those people
[Music]
yeah what movie ah i don't know maybe
the breakfast club that's exactly wow
i've seen that movie so many times a lot
of white people in that movie yeah all
white people that's my love that's just
all the people i've dated she got
obsessed with dog breeds in the bible
so this question is 10 years old 10
years old
this question is just what dog breed
would you be
i think i would probably be a german
shepherd because i'm uh i'm pretty
intelligent that's just a punk hustler i
like to travel like i like to do things
like outdoorsy things although i'm not
really aggressive over like protective
so i guess maybe not
you aspire to german shepherdness i just
want a german shepherd truthfully did we
talk about did we talk about your dating
history
oh his
we did is that important we we
curious we don't want to know how this
happens you guys cut me off because i
said i was a nerd oh yeah yeah i wanted
to know about that more but go on
does miniature board gaming get you a
lot of [ __ ]
no
surprise surprise uh what is your dating
history like
you know i've had a couple of girls like
a couple of long-term girlfriends
and that's it you know like oh
i feel bad yeah i kind of just like you
hop into that you're like oh you like me
i'm going to keep you forever
that's so sweet yeah
it hasn't worked out yet how long is
long term
two to three years yeah yeah
okay at least two years
then like three and a half years was my
longest
so what about you holly what's your
dating life like you have you literally
have a boyfriend yeah oh yeah by the way
spoiler oh there he goes
back to the bleachers see it's naked uh
well i'm done with this date well okay
uh medium rare medium rare can i say i
actually like it medium rare i'm a bad
[ __ ] i like it rare i just want people
to pitch i'm not at all surprised
like sucking up that blood off the plate
oh i like to squeeze out the blood and i
like to mix the blood with my mashed
potatoes it's so gross
and i love it enough talk about your
period let's talk about your steak
preferences uh
one last question uh for the both of you
uh
what
why where who uh
so you guys are uh
both influence let's do
an improv exercise you guys are both
tick-tock influencers and you're living
in the same influencer's house and
you're going to make a sketch together
and you're just ideating and trying to
come up with a sketch go ahead and
talk it out with each other you guys are
both
huge influencers
and you just you guys are just
collaborating and
it's going to go great
what was that skit where they dumped ice
on each other's head the als bucket
challenge yeah that wasn't a skit that
was like a fundraiser for als
all right you all right yeah you know
that sick brand uh als yeah they
sponsored it
and
is that it unseen yeah wow
uh is that is there anything you guys
want to say to each other before you
leave wait
i like your hat thank you enjoy you
store drugs what's your favorite for do
i store drugs call you autistic and
racist we love you holly
good luck with your white boyfriend
with the mullet
and thank you heather for coming out
give it up for heather keith you can
check her out on adult kiddo
go visit her everywhere she goes please
do
and uh yeah thank you for coming out
that was the show uh let's now play some
royalty-free music and uh
have a good night drive home tower
yeah give it up for her tower have a
good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]